they flew you in you were guests and
Madame Tussauds or something wax what of
you we saw pictures a picture of you
there you do you remember like the last
time
you weren't famous like the last time
you were walking along going hey nobody
on the street knows me
that's Dell that was a long time ago so
there's is there any way in the world
you can go where you aren't famous yeah
I just haven't been there yet really it
was really strange though it's like men
and black is everywhere on earth yeah
and with these ears you can't hide
because this this is the problem
everywhere in the world as well Smith
[Applause]
last time I was here I did my Fresh
Prince rap
8 million YouTube hits was on that I can
see your face you like what has he left
well this time I brought my DJ Jazzy
Jeff
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh here we go here we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't think it finished yet Jeff I
don't think that better already
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
soft your granny when you were starting
out with your music then I shocked my
granny yeah Salter shot my granny I want
to be real hardcore
sorry granny grandma bye
that's for Graham norm defined you know
my my rep book I started I started
writing my raps when I was about 12 so I
had my book and you know I want you know
I want to be a rapper so I had all of my
curse words and use my four-letter words
and and everything in there and my
grandmother found my rap book she never
said anything and she just turned to the
back page and she wrote dear Willard
that's my you know you knew that was my
real I got willing you think yeah yeah
I'll just use will coz Willard feels
weird she was a dear Willard
truly intelligent people do not have to
use words like this to express
themselves please show the world that
you're as smart as we think you are love
Gigi from that point I never put
profanity in my rap music but a little
bit of a injury
it's called dog jaw yeah I don't know do
you have you ever
[Music]
this was you with a crowd in Miami a
couple of weeks ago here's the thing so
you take pictures of people yes and what
we found out looking at these pictures
of you with your fans people you've
asked for pictures and things Will Smith
is a practitioner of the phenomenon
known as hopper hands hover hands so
it's that thing when you're posing for a
picture with someone yeah you do the arm
[Music]
it's just a hopper this is a cut this is
will doing hover hands this is very this
casick hopper answers here look hard and
just that Harvard
yeah but no because you is strangers you
can't just you can't just be touching
people you know but I hacked because I
had I used to have old styles of taking
pictures you know I try I tried a couple
things I'll show you how I used to so so
one of my first ones was the the you
know when I was young it was the pelvic
lead you know so this was I usually take
pictures with all the fans and then I
felt like this wasn't you know yeah it's
not appropriate right
no I switch you to prom
[Applause]
the most appropriate you mind doing a
mass hover hands over here okay so come
down here no you sat in the front row
and now you're not in it no okay seven
stand up stand up stand up okay oh you
know you go kamiya all right here okay
so we're around here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
step down step down sit down
so hover okay
look in the lens they're ready you ready
ready
[Applause]
[Music]
you